voix de blindés russes qui s'avance vers
la capitale ukrainienne se divisent
maintenant en groupes plus restreints au
nord et à l'ouest de kiev est en crue
semble s'être dispersés comme le
montrent les dernières images satellites
on y voit aussi des pièces d'artillerie
cacher dans les bois certaines en
position de tir les forces de vladimir
poutine sont présentes sur plusieurs
fronts autour de la capitale et
resserrent leur étau aux portes de la
ville les combats font rage les villes
de boudhha d'hosto mais les dires pin
résiste difficilement poussant les
habitants à fuir c'est à pied qu'il
traverse cette rivière sans savoir où
aller un patron de doc ce leur donne la
bénédiction
regardez ce sont les cadeaux qui sont
envoyées du ciel ce sont ces stupides
russe qui tuent des civils
au sud-ouest de la capitale les chars
russes aussi ne sont pas très loin alors
la population se prépare
et des civils de la défense territoriale
on n'est pas préparé à 10 contre des
chars mais on combattra les troupes au
sol
on a 26 kalachnikov calibre 5,45 mais il
n'y en a pas assez pour tout le monde au
nord-est la région de brovary est en
proie à de lourds de bataille c'est par
là que passe l'autoroute principale
menant à kiev les soldats ukrainiens
doivent donc absolument en garder le
contrôle d'autant qu'une grande partie
est déjà tombée aux mains des russes en
cinq jours les chars russes ont avancé
de plus de 80 km
non on a peur m'a fait mais pas payé je
sais qu'on nous défend on n'a pas peur
je n'ai pas peur j'ai de la nied ti pour
mes enfants et mes petits-enfants je
n'ai peur
j'étais militaire pendant l'époque
soviétique l'otan est une organisation
puissante alors pourquoi elle a peur de
défendre le craignent
de toutes parts la capitale ukrainienne
et donc encerclé son centre a déjà été
vidé de la moitié de ses habitants